anybody else here married San Diego
where's your girl at she failed ge's up
dog she ain't here like you have fun G's
up bro this how I know is a good dude
his girl didn't come and then he was
like you know what I'll do I'll hang out
with my homie when you cheat on your
wife with your friend that's good man
right there dog he's like I'mma cheat on
this with a good
time I do love being married though
what's your favorite part of being
married oh I just had a kid you just had
a kid my second kid so yeah second kid
how old are you 30 hey you long time for
a Latino that's you know very patient
you W young I thought you might be 21 I
was like that makes sense that tracks
you know my favorite thing I got no kids
so you know my favorite thing about
being married this guy said no kids I'm
Indian I need to have kids soono and I
need to pump out a couple doctors cuz I
didn't make it I'm going to be the
Indian lar I'm really going to push my
kids into being surgeons I'm going to
mold them into the greatest
cardiac surgeons in the American history